die berliner familie burgdorf nach einem
jahr corona alle sind zu hause alle
beschäftigt am computer ok fast alle
leandro kämpft mit mathematik
der 14 jährige sitzt bis zu neun stunden
am tag am laptop knall voller
stundenplan plus hausaufgaben leandro
muss sich manchmal selbst zum
homeschooling zwingen keine lust hätte
nichts
man klickt dazu sagen schon fast ein
bisschen depressiv sein also ist
wirklich ein großes wort depressiv sein
aber schon fast also das ist krass man
wird traurig sein weil man will nichts
mehr machen
auch mutter paola ist im homeschooling
sie ist lehrerin und will die kinder
endlich wieder in der schule
unterrichten
die korona impfung würde das erleichtern
aber auf die impfung muss paola warten
bis sie angeschrieben wird für mich
persönlich eine sehr gute nachricht dann
weiß ich habe einen impftermin die
impfungen kommen nur schleppend voran in
deutschland erst zehn prozent der
bevölkerung sind geimpft die menschen
über 80 das personal in krankenhäusern
und pflegeheimen carola burgdorf kann
sich nicht einfach in eine schlange vorm
im zentrum einreihen
sie bereitet sich jetzt auf die lang
ersehnten schnelltests in der schule vor
bald soll es auch in ihrer schule
losgehen selbst test machen die schule
sicherer aber in deutschland sind die
tests noch immer mangelware
paola sorgt sich dass sie den kontakt zu
ihren schülern verliert und es kommt
nichts zurück da macht man sich
natürlich gedanken wo sie eigentlich
vater marc hat sich sein home office im
schlafzimmer eingerichtet
besser als das findet er
in der pandemie mit bus und bahn zur
arbeit fahren das gilt als riskant aber
im europäischen vergleich ist
deutschland nur durchschnitt in der home
office nutzung mit unter 40 prozent der
beschäftigten aber auch zuhause 70 mag
ziemlich herausgefordert es ist doch
anspruchsvoll manchmal die berufliche
gedankenwelt und berufliche aura die
eben darum gibt und dann mit kind und
frau zuhause zu verbinden dass es
manchmal eine sportliche gesamt messung
gedanklich beschäftigt sich mit der
zukunft nach der pandemie
er leitet ein start-up mit ideen für
einen neuen tourismus nach der korona
krise und alle zusammen sind die
burgdorf sehr dankbar dass sie bis jetzt
gesund durch die pandemie gekommen sind